wir wollen weiter über dieses video
sprechen das ganz deutschland schockiert
wie die polizei einen jugendlichen in
einem park gejagt weil er offenbar gegen
die korona regeln verstoßen haben könnte
und dazu wollen wir jetzt mit der
polizei sprechen mit rainer wendt er ist
chef der deutschen polizeigewerkschaft
und uns jetzt zugeschaltet herzlichen
guten abend hallo was ging ihnen des
herzens durch den kopf als sie dieses
video gesehen haben oder zumindest nicht
die dramatik die die bilder hier
vermitteln und die teilweise auch in den
wortmeldungen dazu kommen er wissen sie
ich bin mehr als vier jahrzehnte lang im
aktiven polizeidienst gewesen und ich
sehe hier zunächst einmal einen jungen
mann weglaufen der offensichtlich
überprüft werden sollte und ich frage
mich bei all den kommentaren die auch im
internet so abgelassen werden was
erwarten die leute eigentlich wenn die
polizei jemanden auffordert sich
auszuweisen und kontrolliert zu werden
und wenn er sich umdreht und wegläuft
sollte polizei die hände in der
hosentasche stecken und sagen okay schön
dass man mal darüber geredet haben
natürlich nicht ich hätte genauso
gehandelt wie meine kolleginnen und
kollegen hier in hamburg auch gehandelt
haben wenn jemand weg läuft wird er
verfolgt und festgestellt und
festgehalten und dann wird er überprüft
das ist ganz normale engagierte
polizeiarbeit deshalb ist dieser einsatz
alles andere als spektakulär
das sieht man dann doch anders wenn wir
nicht bei der polizei ist denn natürlich
eine kontrolle das ist keine frage dass
es in ordnung und der sollte man sich
auch stellen und nicht wegrennen wenn
ein jugendlicher dann aber doch wenn man
muss noch mal sagen es war jetzt keine
schwere straftat die ihm vorgeworfen
worden ist und er dann durch einen park
mit einem auto verfolgt wird dass es vor
allem der punkt der uns und viele andere
menschen erschrocken hat es ist ja
wirklich gefährlich sowohl für die
kollegen als auch für den man es sieht
aus als wäre er würde er keine 10 cm von
dem auto wenn dann gefallen wäre wäre
das auto war über gefahren die gefahren
sind ja viel viel größer als das was ihm
tatsächlich vorgeworfen wird dass er es
mit seinen freunden getroffen hat und
dann anscheinend abgeklatscht hat
jemanden um abend hat als sie sich zu
nah gekommen ist in corona zeiten also
erst mischung stört ist die verbindung
hier ausschließlich mit dieser corona
kontrolle wir wissen zunächst einmal
nicht warum eine person sich einer
kontrolle erziehen entziehen möchte
wir wissen auch nicht wer das ist der
dort weg läuft ob er möglicherweise
wegen anderer straftaten gesucht wird
den wir nur wegen eines eines kroner
verstoßes seine personalien angeben soll
und dann weg läuft der macht sich
zumindest verdächtig möglicherweise auch
noch andere dinge verbergen zu wollen
insofern weiß man erst hinterher
welche welche um welche personen es sich
dort handelt und zweitens der einsatz
des streifenwagens der ist ja nun unser
handwerkszeug und dieser streifenwagen
da ist gibt benutzt worden um ihm den
weg abzuschneiden auch das ist ein
ziemlich unspektakulär vorgang natürlich
wenn man ihn mit lautem martinshorn
zieht und dann auch noch mit musik
unterlegt und dann sieht das alles
ziemlich dramatisch aus glauben sie mir
ich habe so etwas noch mal erlebt in
meiner aktiven zeit daran ist überhaupt
nicht spektakulär und ja ganz
offensichtlich ist der streifenwagen
durch ein schlagloch beschädigt worden
wenn wir alle schlaglöcher vorher kennen
dann haben wir es viel leichter und
glauben sie mir wenn ich vor angst aus
angst vor einem möglicherweise
auftretenden schlagloch mit dem
streifenwagen nicht erst losfahren
sollen dann hätten wir in berlin
überhaupt keine polizei auf den straßen
aber erwähnt eine frage dazu noch wir
haben gerade ein statement von der
hamburger polizei gesehen und auch dort
wird gesagt die aufnahme man wird sie
die auf jeden fall in ruhe noch mal
anschauen das zeigt dass es nicht ganz
normales was da zu sehen ist also selbst
ihre kollegen zeigen ja schon das ist
ein paar offene fragen auch innerhalb
der polizei gibt überhaupt nicht auch
das ist ein völlig normaler vorgang dass
polizei solche einsätze zumal wenn sie
dann in der öffentlichkeit so dramatisch
dargestellt und diskutiert werden
noch einmal nach bereitet die
kolleginnen und kollegen werden befragt
was habt ihr wie hat sich die situation
vor ort dargestellt auch daran ist
überhaupt nichts ungewöhnliches
also ich habe gerade nun auch die
bildberichterstattung dazu gelesen ich
vertraue darauf dass sie richtig ist und
ich kenne die polizeiliche realität noch
einmal daran ist nichts dramatisches
es ist viel zu dramatisch und was da
manchmal unter dem aspekt der
verhältnismäßigkeit diskutiert wird das
können nur leute so diskutieren die die
polizeiarbeit nicht kennen
wie schwierig ist es denn für die
polizei die jetzt in dieser pandemie ist
zusätzliche aufgabe bekommen hat sie
hygieneregeln die korona regeln zu
überwachen vor was für schwierigkeiten
stellt das vielleicht auch manchmal die
beamten nutzen können die großen
widersprüche in der bevölkerung es gibt
viele demonstrationen die stattfinden
gegen die korona vorschriften und
widersprüchlicher sie sind und die
zögerliche die politik in die eine oder
andere richtung geht umso schwieriger
ist es vor ort für die kolleginnen und
kollegen das dann auch durchzusetzen
es gibt viele situationen sobald das
schöne wetter los geht beispielsweise um
menschen glauben die sonnenstrahlen die
schützen dann auch vor kroner das ist
ausdrücklich nicht der fall
und insofern haben die kolleginnen und
kollegen es wirklich nicht leicht und
sie müssen teilweise in sekunden und in
sekundenbruchteilen entscheiden was zu
tun ist wenn eine person sich umdreht
und wegläuft und sich der polizeilichen
kontrolle entzieht noch einmal dann ist
es ganz normales tageswerk der polizei
dass diese person gestellt und
kontrolliert wird mehr nachrichten und
breaking news nur bei bate schaue ich
hier das nächste video an und vergiss
nicht zu abonnieren